but I believe that once a month once
every two weeks we should be having
dinners with smart fun people yes just
let's make a higher they got to come
cook let's sit around have a meal and
eat some goddamn food you're more than
what you and if you invite me I'll go
not yet Kat you're too young you're a
gal can I can I tell you something yeah
I'm gonna take you to dinner because of
what he just Jesus no I like Kat I don't
know oh I don't know what either but I
just invited her dad is my brother right
there Chin's coming he's definitely not
your brother bye how there's a deep
thing we have the same mom mom so you
have the same mother we do what is her
name
Michelle jennifer Michelle it's a
hyphenated name - Jennifer Michelle
where and where were you born
Seoul Korea and where was he born Sumner
yeah you were born in South Korea in
that area yeah what's the what is it
would like where what specifically
daddy's sorry
so where he was talking about same spot
in the same yeah pretty much the same
the same hospital
Wow what's the age difference right now
yeah at this said right now the age
difference is exactly 11 years yeah 11
years yeah he's your little brother yeah
okay can I tell you something yeah it
all adds up I believe every piece of it
every set everything adds up I'm making
cats a dinner because of what you just
said yeah I also want to come too you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
her to lunch and then come to your
dinner with the fun thing and I might
bring her you're gonna crash the dinner
with her she'll be my she's on your arm
it's Nant were married yeah yeah but on
my arm I don't I don't own her Agnes
[ __ ] are you pregnant no but she will be
with your redheaded baby and and you'll
be beating her what do you do said it
yeah that I did say it what kind of we
would have a very odd-looking baby oh
you're both good-looking people
yeah but not half asian half red that
could be tough he's not scared of Cyrus
he the most beautiful I love this
attitude I love this attitude yeah but
but but you're talking about a kind of
white I'm a unique species of why you
guys gotta be careful cuz you might just
fall in love what do you think I'm doing
over here
because he looks like a he looks like a
very Anglo white if someone says yeah
yeah if someone said half Sicilian I
know but you look white yeah you have a
white man it says who what's a white man
they'd probably draw you yeah I had a
director say that because I never
recognize you I go I goes you just look
like every man you look like a married
Gary fleeter my buddies but but thanks
Carol this this is a nice point isn't it
nice to to look like just I got a guy's
guy a guy there's not like look guys
guys in the business I got shoulders for
days my waist is so tapered I got a dick
on me and so there's a lot of stuff
going on I stick killers shoulders
humble - I'm humble I got a nice dick I
got him killed his shoulders and I got a
lot of fast twitch muscle which is why I
can almost dunk a basketball oh my
that's two more inches of [ __ ] bone
if there's one thing that you need in
your life that you could change what
would it be
I'd like to be less impulsive I'd like
to be good luck yeah I'd like to be less
neurotic I guess I'm used to things
literally yeah usually can't change him
no and I don't know if I want it if
somebody of the day I am Who I am I'm a
flawed very flawed yeah very very very
very flaw oh my god oh my god oh my
there's a blog called flawed flawed very
flawed calm calm I contribute what I
think about this though what if someone
came up to you I had this like daydream
in the shower sometimes a guy from Dubai
I don't know wise to buy because I like
to buy and he's like I'll give you five
hundred million dollars to quit the
business disappear forever would you do
it first of all I didn't know he was
from Dubai but of Spanish or would you
hear it that's very good for five
hundred million five hundred dollars you
kill you quit you quit would you quit
the business for a half million dollars
and disappear it's a very good question
and the answer might be yes and here's
why hmm I would I since I've done it
yeah I feel it
you've already been in the business yeah
for 32 years dedicate myself to
something completely different and it
might be something as simple as golf
literature and just writing oh I think
my golf is a golf literature it's just
all about golf because literature is
just all about stories about gall fiber
TV stations fiction no got Bagger Vance
you read
Bagger Vance I'll write a Bagger Vance
story over and over again that's cute
thank you
yeah I don't know I've hundred I think I
might leave the business do it every day
in the shower I think would you I have a
daydream every day every single before I
came to this [ __ ] thing are you at a
daydream in the morning of a man coming
up to me on the street grabbing me
throwing me in a van and going 500
million why is that because I want to
get out of this business I hate it so my
[ __ ] hate it I really appreciate all
saying is a nightmare why do people
think it's fun it's such a hustle dude
it sucks
it's dog sad people don't realize what a
[ __ ] hustle it is and it's up to me
every single day to figure out a way to
make money
hence neuroses hence tenseness hence
psoriasis
yeah seriously you know where this guy
my mother said that to me my pressure
yeah I have so much pressure on my
shoulders like a poopa diamond today I
could [ __ ] out a diamond this afternoon
I'm in the middle of my [ __ ] in the
middle of buying a house Oh God put a
gun on my [ __ ] I don't shoot my penis
right off my body houses are so cheap in
lausanne and they're easy to buy give
out loans I just throw them at you they
don't look like every [ __ ] detail I I
know all about that they had I to take
pictures of my shoes they had to wonder
they want to know what kind of shoes I
had it's the most disgusting you're
almost you know you're joking but it's
it is a bit invasive it's invasive it's
almost that of video now tell us you're
they wanted to know well they make sure
the money's not laundered that's the
home stolen they wanted most in to make
sure what happened but god I wish I was
around in 2006 when they were giving
away [ __ ] houses you know if you just
had eyes to eyeballs yeah if you were
awake they give you a house my gardener
got along for real but is it foreclosed
on though or hey my gardener about
$500,000 a year well first of all my
grounds go on for you know as far as you
can see and what do you gotta do
something with this you've got a nine or
ten acres out there don't ya I do
Jesus Hollywood in the dead center of
Hollywood got ten acres of land with you
won't see it because the wall is so
[ __ ] high so we bought we just bought
a half bed half bath it's sixteen square
feet that's really small Andrew no what
do mean that size no I mean I don't mean
to be in self oh it just seems now let's
have a [ __ ] new show let's have a
bedroom have half bed half bath 16
square feet there is a we don't call it
a driveway we call it an up way because
it's a pube chunks of concrete go near
the front door every million
it's two and a half yeah it's two and a
half oh you can't look at a place if you
come in if you come in to buy a house in
Los Angeles I'm sorry to everybody out
there this is the truth yeah if you go
if you want to buy a house and you have
1 million dollars which is a shitload
not a million nobody has a million but
if you can a finance if you finance a
million American dollars financing so
you can put 200 grand down they will let
you when you look at the houses
available for a million dollars you'll
you're not getting a yard you're not
getting anything you don't get any
they'll laugh at you yeah don't laugh
the ruger will be like the roof is
separate you have to pay for the room
absolutely it's that [ __ ] up I've
never I've never felt so disgusted when
I when I started looking for a house
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]